let's talk about some other people being
put through some stuff from Politico
lawyers bail on my pillows Mike Lindell
saying he owes millions in fees and Mike
Lindell is saying he is facing multiple
IRS audits this is what happens when you
go up against corruption there are evil
people in government there have been for
a long time they are working in
intelligence agencies they are abject
evil their goals are for
self-preservation and for self-benefit
and if you exercise your rights as aner
they will do everything they can to
destroy you don't take my word for it
how about Chuck Schumer six ways from
Sundays if you piss them off is that the
American way that the intelligence
agencies run this country and you have
no right you have no say and only by
their good graces are we allowed to
function in society I reject that yeah I
I mean we know that IRS has a very bad
record especially when it came to going
after people for political purposes
especially under the Obama
Administration which they were caught
red-handed doing I I think it's fair to
say that that's exactly what's happening
right now to to Mike lell and uh he's
not the first one I think what happened
to Alex Jones is the first kind of
financial attack and cancellation that
is being utilized by the system and
establishment to try to bleed out the
resources try to stop any kind of uh of
just power and authority from human
beings being able just to speak out just
to be able to silence them by taking
away all of their money all of their
resources has been let's be honest here
somewhat of an effective strategy by The
Establishment and it's a scary one
because you look at these stories you're
like am I going to get audited am I
going to be able to find lawyers as of
course lawyers are literally being
indicted as well um so it's it's just uh
I think this is lawfare I I think this
is a weaponized doj justice system that
has been financed and bankrolled by
George Soros who of course is
weaponizing District Attorneys all
throughout the United States and this is
why I think it's important to to live in
places that actually represent your
ideas not just because of the
possibility of this kind of law fair but
if if there's even an incident where you
have to defend yourself you want a jury
that actually respects the right of
human beings to protect themselves a lot
of democratic places don't have that at
all they have district attorneys that
will punish you for just even standing
up for yourself which is crazy it's
mindboggling well this is also less than
two weeks after American Express came
out and said that they were severely
limiting Michael lindell's credit limit
and that's what his business relies on
like he's he's making hundreds of
millions of a year in revenue and has a
very functioning business servicing
millions of Americans so what you're
seeing here is weaponization of
government and also the weaponization of
private Enterprise together in tandem to
silence someone because of his political
views what's severely ironic about all
of this is that the progressive
authoritarians in society that conduct
this type of Madness will accuse us of
being fascists when the actual
definition of fascism is an
authoritarian government and private
Enterprise partnering together to stifle
the views of political opposition that's
exactly what's happening here and they
want to send a very loud message that if
you dare speak up as a business owner or
as a politician or as a community leader
or as a podcast host or whatever it
might be if you dare speak up they will
weaponize private and public Enterprise
against you in your values and your
family they're doing it to Rudy Giuliani
I mean it's it's absurd what's happening
I don't know if any of you have met Mike
but Mike is one of the nicest kindest
and most generous people I've ever met
in my life he's he's uh always wants to
be helpful he always tries to build
people up you know he's been financially
impactful on so many lives of
conservatives you know a lot of
conservatives have a hard time finding
advertisers and Mike Lindell was right
there to step up and so not only are
they going after Mike they're going
after all of those people that he's
supporting Steve Bannon one of his big
advertisers is my pillow if you look at
a lot of these podcasters my pillow like
subsidizes a lot of these people when
there was a boycott on Tucker Carlson it
was Mike Lindell that stepped up and
said I'm going to promote my pillows on
the Tucker Carlson show I mean at a
certain point people can only have so
many pillows right what you
but build a pillow fort she has like 40
pillows on her bed I think it was just
so many Americans saw what they were
doing to Mike canceling him because of
his political beliefs and and I think
that's why Public Square has been such a
rocket to the moon um because people
want to shop with their values and say
maybe I need three pillows or four
pillows every 3 months now and just cuz
I want to support Mike Lindell because
this guy sacrificed a lot just because
you know and so well he's got towels and
bathrobes and slippers bed sheets not
just pillows I'm just is he on Public
Square he is and uh we're actually he's
he's we're becoming close uh he's he's
an amazing man I Echo Alex's thoughts
this is a part of a broader theme too of
cancelling advertisers we saw with
Rumble two weeks ago in the whole
Russell Brand thing Burger King
hellofresh pulling so something we're
trying to do at Public Square we have
70,000 plus small businesses that all
want to advertise in the parallel
economy so now we're trying to push them
to creators and say hey you've got now
creators a network of advertisers that
will not cancel you here's the next
thing you do you're already you're
probably already doing it and you are
doing it to a certain extent is create
the backend portal for social media
networking so then the the thing people
need to understand about YouTube is that
the bulk of the revenue you YouTubers
get is not from big companies from small
companies small a small Diner in a local
area with a few thousand people will
spend 50 bucks putting out ads so that
the videos appear and then if you're you
know you're living in this town and
you're watching a YouTube video the
commercial you see will for will be for
L Diner down the street and they're only
spending 50 bucks but when you add all
of those little diners you the YouTube
Creator ends up getting a couple Grand
or something like that creating that uh
there there have been a bunch of
attempts at this throughout in the past
where companies have popped up and said
if you're a YouTuber sign up and then we
connect you with sponsors that are
looking for Content or whatever the only
problem is YouTube had automated it yep
the issue now is advertisers are pulling
out of YouTube
activists are threatening people to try
and get advertisers pulled so I think I
don't know if you guys are already IDE
if you're already working on it but if
you sign up and you say like hey I make
content then you can see people being
like our budget for advertising this
month is 25 to 50 bucks here's what
we're looking to promote and then you
basically like accept and then message
them and then boom now you've got an
automated system for people who make
content to make money and promote
products build that parallel economy
it's a brilliant idea because you have
literally tens of thousands of business
across the country that have felt
disenfranchised rejected by Yelp Google
Trip Advisor these platforms are no
longer built for the interests of small
businesses especially not ones that have
conservative leanings and so they're
asking us every day how do we get more
involved in the parallel economy when
they see budlight and Target tank that
$30 billion doesn't just eviscerate it's
got to go somewhere
consumer right well and so if you can if
you can actually shift the advertising
world to be one that's cancel proof like
and then the parallel economy can kind
of broker all those interactions like
it's a very powerful impenetrable force
hey look uh Ultra right conservative
dad's beer what what did what did Seth
Sell like two million bucks in like 12
hours after the Trump picture half a
million in 12 hours a million within
like a day or two and then he says by
the time he closes out it'll be like $2
million amazing man just I just want
everybody to listen okay cuz you know a
lot of people are like how do I succeed
in life and you got so many people that
are willing to dump thousands of dollars
into these get-rich quick programs where
like go to a seminar and a guy's like
I'm going to teach you the secrets to
success and here's a dude Seth weather's
like Bud light's nasty so I'm going to
sell beer and how he just sold a couple
million dollars worth of beer so if
you're looking how to what to do help
build the parallel economy invest in a
small business or a product do what you
can to say f you to the the corporations
that despise you Mike Lindell paved the
way yeah it's true and they hate them
for it you know there's so many creators
that probably would never have been able
to get their voice voices heard if it
weren't for Mike and uh you know Mike's
a patriot and we'll pray for him and uh
it's sick what they're doing to the guy
but I know the guy's a fighter and he's
a man of faith and so I think he he
knows he'll get out of this but uh
they've been putting this guy through
hell for three years now y well they did
the same to Alex Jones and Alex Jones is
very persistent he's he's still able to
survive there's also a lot of lawsuits
happening right now against Tucker
Carlson there's another big lawsuit
against Elon Musk so these people are
being attacked I believe in a
coordinated way to try to of course
stifle any kind of resistance any kind
of speech Against The Establishment so I
don't think a lot of these incidences or
or coincidences I do think there is
something top down happening here are
you guys working on any kind of like
social component because we've had
people ask us about that yeah to a
degree um the world of social commerce
is growing a lot like you even see Tech
talk starting to play with some Commerce
ideas um which is a disaster in just a
Chinese data mining Farm but that said
we have uh the desire to get more into
the world of Connecting People locally
to businesses and other consumers where
you can actually like follow a local
business get exclusive discounts because
you're following local businesses and be
a part of kind of the cast Brew Network
right so you're a part of a local Club
essentially that is partnered in loyalty
to these different businesses the the
other thing that's interesting and you
bring this up and my encouragement to
any young entrepreneurs people that are
fascinated in the parallel economy
over12 trillion in asset are going to
transfer in the next8 Years between the
baby boomer run businesses down to the
Next Generation 12 trillion in assets so
we have two options one is those baby
boomer run businesses can either
disappear into the ether that's awful
they can be bought up by Blackstone on
the private Equity side and transformed
against our values or they can be
purchased by Patriots and turned into
incredible sources for the parallel
economy my my recommendation go on like
acquire. comom there are all these sites
where these small businesses are up for
sale and if you're good at marketing and
you can grow like you can purchase a
business for
$20,000 and transform it sales and now
all of a sudden you have this incredible
tool to capitalize on the need for
Americans to have alternative Solutions
now you can only really do that if
you're genuine like you have to actually
believe in it otherwise no we should
hone in on this because throughout human
history it has always been predominantly
private Enterprise business and
capitalism that has saved people from
the woes and problems that the
government has started and I truly do
believe that voting with your dollar is
way more important than voting every
four freaking years you have a choice
you could support C Brew you could
support the weor change. shop you could
support businesses made in America on
public Street or you could support the
pope rotchild inclusive capitalism ESG
Black Rock scams that are screwing you
over and literally taking your money and
running psychological operations and a
war against you in the fifth generation
this is something that I think people
need to understand now more than ever
you're if you're buying Starbucks if
you're buying Netflix if you're buying
from Disney what are you doing what
money where are you putting your energy
towards what are you getting in response
to that usually seed oils usually
usually harmful stuff you could be
supporting so many different companies
so many different organizations and
allowing ideas to be sponsored by your
energy thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8:00 p.m. and become a member over at
timcast.net